ladies and gentlemen it is uh an
historic day
we now know that uh thanks to
democrats winning both senate runoffs
in georgia uh democrats will have
50 50 in the senate with
joe biden in the white house meaning
that in any cases of a 50-50
tie in the senate the vice president
kamala harris
will be allowed to cast the deciding
vote in practical terms
giving democrats control of the senate
what they will be able to get done of
course will depend
on maintaining all 50 democratic
senators
united and it's almost cliche at this
point to say
but much of that will come down to does
joe manchin
the most conservative of the democrats
in the senate from west virginia
does joe manchin want to do many of the
things that joe biden
outlined uh in his presidential platform
or will joe manchin be the thorn in the
side of the democrats now of course
there are other democrats who in some
cases may not want to go with the biden
idea
there are at least theoretically some
republicans who might
you know the prototypical example is
that
the constituents for republican maine
senator susan collins
may maybe more to the left of the
constituents
for democratic senator in west virginia
joe manchin
and these are more detail-level
discussions that we will have
in the future but what we do know uh
is that in terms of the kelly lefler
incumbent versus challenger raphael
warnock
race that one was called relatively
early last night
official calls starting around and after
midnight
david wasserman unofficially saying he
had seen enough of the data
to call it right around i believe it was
9 30 p.m eastern maybe 10 p.m eastern
something like that
and indeed that race has been now called
officially with rafael warnock ahead as
of right now with 98
reporting by 1.2 percentage points
the other race is incumbent senator
david perdue
a corrosive vile depraved influence on
the u.s
senate um who couldn't even be at the
last
rally that donald trump held for the
republicans because he was
in isolation due to covet exposure
that one has has been called by some
and not others but uh it is it is over
and officially as of right now john
ossoff with 98
reporting as of this moment um leading
by about half a point roughly 16 17
000 votes um and uh that one is also one
that some have called and some have not
and by the time you listen to today's
show you may see that
it has also been called so consider that
under donald trump who won in 2016.
donald trump himself is ending up as a
one-term president and we are just
moments now and maybe by the time you
listen to this it will already be
underway
we are moments now from the official
counting of the electoral votes january
6 the absolute
i think last date that trump cultists
were saying
this is the date where mike pence can do
something for us
um but trump becoming a one-term
president
democrats taking the house of
representatives in 2018
and maintaining control in 2020 although
with a slightly smaller margin than they
than they achieved in 2018
and democrats also taking the senate
from republicans in 2020.
back in 2017 the mathematical consensus
was pointing to
unlikely that democrats can take the
senate in 2020
but 2022 is certainly a possibility we
now have a situation where democrats
thanks of course to kamala harris in the
white house
democrats now will have control 50
plus that one tiebreaking vote in the
senate in 2020
and the possibility again depends on
what you get done
but the possibility of expanding the
senate majority
in 2022 although we are very much
getting ahead of ourselves let's get
this
new president sworn in first and
foremost um
i was thinking by the way back to
remember that uh
debate between kelly lefler and
challenger rafael warnock where she
endlessly repetitively smeared or
attempted to smear him
as radical liberal remember this radical
liberal raphael warnock
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock
radical liberal rafael warnock radical
liberal rafael warnock
well as i tweeted last night that's
going to have to be modified
to be radical liberal senator
rafael warnock to you ms leffler and of
course
he's not really radical and that was
just part of the smear campaign
so in the end you know we'll look at
exit polls and we already know that
perspective on trump versus biden
heavily influenced people's votes in
georgia
we know that there was some antipathy
towards donald trump's attempts to steal
the election that joe biden legally won
and legally won
quite easily i i might add that did not
work in donald trump's favor
and we'll have time to slice and dice
the results but in the immediate
the question for me becomes listen
politics is not sport for me
politics is how does this affect
people's lives and unfortunately there
there are many for whom it is merely
sport and that's really a shame
but we have a global hundred year
pandemic we have an eviction crisis
we have high unemployment we've seen
dramatic gdp reductions
we have businesses that are closed for
good because of the virus
we've seen growing inequality and
there's this long and climate
is is an urgent crisis so there's this
long list here of
issues that joe biden is going to have
dropped on his desk
on day one what can he do via executive
order
what can he do legislatively in the
first hundred days
joe biden talking yesterday about if we
get these seats then we're looking at
two thousand dollar checks well are you
and how quickly can you get that done
is that something we're going to do i uh
joined up yesterday
during our broadcast of the georgia
results
with uh sam cedar over and and emma over
at the
majority report and we talked about um
what is the uh what is the trajectory
here
in terms of what's prioritized with
regard to the virus
sam's saying well biden should
immediately invoke the defense
production act
and get businesses making a millions and
millions of doses of the vaccine
to accelerate that process because the
sooner we reach herd immunity the sooner
the economy is going to recover
and the sooner we can get back to
dealing with a whole bunch of other
issues i think that that's something
that's going to have to be looked at but
uh for those who my last thought on this
i want to go to republican reaction to
this
but my last thought and you know part of
the conversation here we can't have
until we actually have
that january 6 today um electoral vote
count in the rear view mirror i think a
lot of us will just
feel more ready to talk about the first
hundred days of this administration and
new senate
but i i think the cautionary message is
all of these are moves in the right
direction but they're small moves we're
just sort of
we've gotten the ball back we're
starting to right the ship
um as i've said before the uh
anti-intellectual anti-science
delusional extremist authoritarian when
we want to be but otherwise we pretend
to be constitutional conservatives that
this entire paradigm on the right was
built up
starting with ronald reagan you could
argue it goes back even further to the
civil rights movement
and and the sort of reaction to the
civil rights movement in the late 50s
and 60s
but let's for our purposes today say
that the
disinformation right that tries to win
by lying to people and
disenfranchising people it sort of goes
back to the reagan era
with the imaginary welfare queen who was
sitting around popping out kids
and making money off welfare to get a
cadillac that that was like the idea she
never existed okay
this that trumpism today and the trump
cult
really started with that and it took
decades to build
and so my only point here and then we'll
move on because there's so much to talk
about my only point here is
everything that's happened in the last
month two months helps us
to start riding the ship but it would be
unreasonable
to imagine that a problem that took 40
years to create is going to be solved in
two
or in four and as i've said before the
only times that you get
radically fast cultural change because a
lot of this comes down to culture
the anti-science culture the hypocrisy
culture of this stuff is all bad
unless we want to do it in which case
it's good that applies to debt
authoritarianism etc from the right um
the only times we see radical changes to
that type of culture
are when you have a dictatorship come in
okay so it's not realistic to think that
a democratic senate and joe biden is
going to
dramatically change that in a two or
four year period so the focus has to be
we get things done that we can get done
and we
start to work on that culture it's a big
uphill battle but
could there were two races and democrats
won both of them you couldn't hope for a
better result
start your day and your new year off
right
with just egg which is one of our
sponsors you've heard me talk about the
importance of having a diet that is
more heavily plant-based than it's
something i've done
over the last few years i've always
loved eggs so it's great
that there is a delicious plant-based
version of egg with all the protein of
egg that just egg brings with it but
it's made from
mung beans so it uses 98 percent less
water
and causes 93 fewer carbon emissions
than a conventional egg
and just egg cooks and tastes exactly
like a conventional egg i've tried it
for
omelets scrambled eggs french toast
banana bread
pad thai anything you'd normally use
eggs for and i actually think if i
cooked something for a friend
without telling them about just egg they
wouldn't even know the difference
find it in the egg aisle at your grocery
store
on amazon prime now or on instacart
and they also have a frozen version
perfect for breakfast sandwiches
just egg try it out